います
もう3月も終わりかけだ
消えていくぞ
ドンウンっ
はいこんにちははじめ雪をネスというわけでも3月防衛かけて貼りやすに終わり方多い
と思いますが僕もですね実はユーチューバー的兄さんがってなんか忙しいとで配給まぁ
ちょっと今しで急がせているんですけども
なんとか3月も頑張って焦げたなと思いますねそうです
金入って行けるですねシャア店まぁ前回の3編の動画ちょっと9億喪失を起こして
しまったんですけども今回は全く多分大丈夫だと思います今までになかったシャーペン
ご紹介しようと思いますぜひ新生活が始まる方とか学校始まる方とか運動が何か変えて
気分一新したいなんて方は是非見てください
こちらまぁまずはこれを詳細したことあるんですよデルガードですね
多分で紹介は紹介を全然したことあると思うんですけどもまぁこれも結構レアが
かなーりグラスんですよ黄色のエルガードで
マーベルガードいいところこちらも作らを込め書いてもさあ芯が折れません今親戚の国
が三振をれるのガードしてて力んじゃって写真おり汗よって方はおすすめのサーベルが
打ってありますでてかも今日のヒーローの格好良いですねこれはた
人権てからなんですよ英語でバングラ dt が飛びましてトランスフォーマーの別の
話みたいなもうなぜ黄色いもで長谷部でめっちゃかっこよく見えるねこれマジですごい
ま
102上げる例ですねベルガード役があるんですけども結構いろんな色のラインアップ
あるんですけども今回みなさんにご紹介するのはマジで覚悟いいです
結局ねシャーペンっていうのはねあのもちろんなんですよ
どんなに良いシャーペン使ってても勉強のやる気が出なかったら意味がないんですよ
そういうことなんです何か聖堂も大事です
もさらに北大事だなと思っているのはカーリングとかデザインだっていい車のつっても
ダサいと嫌でしょ
いい車の轍も色が例えば変だったら嫌でしょということなんです皆さんが好きな色とか
じゃ匹がでいるがあると思いますけどそれはサーフィン一緒できないろ好きなデザイン
のサーフィンを使ってたらメインじゃやる気が自ずと出てくるんですそれがいるよ
持っベーション
やつなんですよ黄色好きな人はこれ使っためっちゃやる気てると面白くもですね赤い
シャーペンとか黒赤魂のとか使ってめっちゃやる気でるんだけどそれで今回みなさんに
ご紹介するのはで zard のんだがめちゃくちゃ
レアなぁカラーリングとかデザインがあるのでそちらをですね全部買いましたいきます
よ
まずはこちらですはい従順でるガートナーベルコラボでございまー
こっちがアイアンマンポロ子ですねあとでしっかり見ていきますのでこれがキャプテン
まゆりたーっ飲んでないって小寺新聞にまあというね
b 1個だけで届くのが遅かったんですよねあなのかなあこれだけめっちゃくるのに
時間かかりました
はいアイアンマンの別カラーでございまー2種類ありますが出るガーゼ使ったことある
んですけどもこのデザインネット見たとき
ええええええかっこいい真剣にマジでかっこいいと思いましただってもマーベルとの
コラボやばいよどうすればこんなカッコイイデザイン作れるんだろうってカッコイイ船
が値段がでね1728円でちょっと高いですマーベルヒーローのように強く
折れないそんなデルガードをもチェックでしたマーブルプラモのでれカードが販売者が
たみたいでございますだいぶ前
なんだよね多分
あと大金だな多分2019年今年の2月3月ぐらいでも出てますねこれはれってがもう
1個あるんだこれ
by 将軍買えなかった奴が食べもう一個ですねスパイダーマンのがあるんですよ
まだ5色展開からね色んな種類があるんですけどそれでボケが支えたのはペット
アイアンマンが2種類とマーベル熱とキャプテンアメリカのやつの4つでございます
ちょっと上げていきましょう
ガードですね何がいいかというとこれ重心がすごい低いんですよ
ちょっとつから込めるだけでセラサーってかけるっていう利点がありますけどまぁクロ
スっこれ入っエマーバックロスねこれはベースが真っ黒になってますって言っますね
これ本当にどんなヒーローってこいですね
もうあいーやーまーぬー
メタリック分ですねーさんの方にキャプテンアメリカのマークが付いてます
エアーおしゃべだなぁ
ペップ煽っていいですよねーそしてアンヤーマンの金赤ですね
てが java 9クリップが黄色なんですよなんだこのただならぬ機高級感はロゴも
しっかり入ってるし編成9あ買ってるもかっこいいですよねこれかっこいいけど僕は
もう1本のこっちの方が多分好きなんですよはい
アイアンマン乗りレッドとゴールドカラーです a子これ何なら一番かっこよくね
やばいよ
ここは一緒なのでここ一緒ですねちょっとラベルコラボ全部かっこいいですねこれ
さらにここにスパイダーマンノアカーをのやつもありますから難いロータスとこんな
感じですね
やはりもうカラーバリエーションがすごい増えてますてるカード卒論を書きやすさも
すごいっすよ俺ないって
4センサーがあるんですごい思いっきりかけますねしっかりとかけるイメージがすごい
です
てかやっぱ金利目指す米金がやっぱり人の目を引く色だと思うんでに僕の好きな花が
達成できるって言うともう1番かっこいいあえて受けていかがでしょうか
全部位ですねー味で戦争を感じますチャプ2アメリカの井田いいな青な感じ
そして相山な熱い心もして鉄板のような近々家とかあっ課金とか今までなかったので
とてもいいところを突いてくださったと思いますぜひ皆さんありがとうございますだけ
でマーベルコラボのシャーペンマジで全裸かっこいいですぜひ皆さんも手に入れてみて
ください
じゃあ
マーベル見たことないんだけどな
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
あっはぁ